my name is luciana berger and i
am the labour and
i am the member of parliament for
liverpool wavertree
this morning we have all now resigned
from the labour party this has been a
very difficult painful but necessary
decision
we represent different parts of the
country
we are of different backgrounds we were
born
of different generations but we all
share
the same values from today
we will all sit in parliament as a new
independent
group of mps
for my part i have become embarrassed
and ashamed to remain in the labour
party
i have not changed the core values of
equality
for all opportunity for all
anti-racism against all and social
justice
the values which i hold really dear and
which led me to join the labour party
as a student almost 20 years ago
remain who i am and yet these values
have been
consistently and constantly violated
undermined and attacked as the labour
party today refuses to put my
constituents
and our country before party interest
i cannot remain in a party
that i have today come to the sickening
conclusion
is institutionally anti-semitic
it was nearly a year ago that we saw the
unprecedented
event of a minority community
the jewish community taking to
parliament square
to demonstrate against the labour party
to say
enough is enough and yet since then
despite a mountain of evidence we have
only seen a situation
of racism against jewish people get
worse
the leadership has willfully and
repeatedly failed to address
hatred against jewish people within its
ranks
and it is for these reasons and many
more that i have made this decision
today
i am leaving behind a culture of
bullying
bigotry and intimidation
i look forward to a future serving with
colleagues who respect each other
and who are committed to working
together for our great country
we will publish a full statement setting
out our position shortly
copies of which will be available at the
end of this morning's event
and on our website my colleagues who i'm
also proud to call my friends
will now set out the reasons why they
have each come to this decision
the principles and values by which we
are guided
and how we intend to operate going
forward as a new
independent group of mps we will of
course
take your questions after everyone has
spoken
thank you
well good morning everybody um and thank
you luciana
uh my name is chris leslie i'm the
member of parliament for nottingham east
this has not been an easy decision for
any of us
we've all been labor members of
parliament for very many years
in my case more than three decades
but the labour party we joined that we
campaigned for and believed in
is no longer today's labour party
we did everything we could to save it
but it has now been hijacked
by the machine politics of the hard left
as luciana said our values haven't
changed
we absolutely oppose this conservative
government and desperately want
an alternative which tackles the
barriers of poverty and discrimination
by extending opportunity for all
but british politics is now well and
truly
broken and in all conscience
we can no longer knock on doors and
support
a government led by jeremy corbyn or the
team
around him why
well for a start the evidence of
labour's betrayal on europe is now
visible for all to see offering to
actually enable
this government's brexit constantly
holding back from allowing the public a
final say
conference policy has been cast aside no
guaranteed full participation in the
single market anymore
no exact same benefits no movement
towards a people's vote
choosing to stand by while our
constituents lives and future
opportunities are hurt by brexit
is a fundamental violation of labor's
traditional values
but our differences go far deeper than
brexit
the past three years have confirmed how
irresponsible it would be
to allow this leader of the opposition
to take the office of prime minister of
the united kingdom
many people still in the labour party
will privately
admit this to be true but we owe it to
our constituents now to say it publicly
and honestly the pursuit of policies
that would threaten our national
security
through hostility to nato the refusal to
act
when needed to help those facing
humanitarian distress
preferring to believe states hostile to
our country
rather than believing our police and
security services
these are all rooted in the labor
leadership's obsession
with a narrow outdated ideology
they're hostile to business large and
small they make impossible
promises which everybody knows in their
hearts
couldn't be kept without putting the
economy at risk and they constantly pit
one part of society against another
because to them
the world divides between oppressor and
oppressed
class enemies when in truth the modern
world
is more complicated than this and then
as luciano was saying there is an
appalling
culture intolerance closing down of
debate
abuse and hatred online as you're seeing
this morning
and offline in party meetings
and anti-semitism so we have no choice
but to say collectively enough is enough
there has to be a better way forward and
there can be a better way forward
thank you
good morning everyone and thank you
chris
my name is angela smith i am the mp
for penniston and stocksbridge in south
yorkshire
i was born to a labour family in 1961
my father was a printer by trade and my
mother started work when
i was a teenager eventually moving on to
a job as a receptionist
in the nhs for my parents
working class pride was not about
enjoying
poverty and wearing it as a badge of
honor
it was about self-respect and believing
that we could
do better that there was nothing wrong
in getting on
in life in 1966
when many other five-year-olds rooted
for england in the world cup
i had my first experience of political
identity
when my mother told me there was a
different competition going on
and that we supported a man called
harold wilson
my family believed that labour
represented their interests
and their values at westminster
underpinning that belief was a sense
that labour would help those who faced
discrimination and barriers when it came
to bringing out the best in themselves
let me tell a brief personal story to
illustrate the point
i went to a village primary and was
recommended by my teachers for the top
stream
at our uniformed local comp it was 1972.
imagine then my parents dismay when i
was placed in the secondary stream
my mother was encouraged to complain to
the head teacher
who could not deny that decisions on the
limited places available
in the top tier had been based partly on
where
we came from we lived in a council house
after one term at my new school i was
advanced to the a stream
but unfortunately the damage was done
i doubted my academic ability and it
hindered progress
it was only when i became an adult that
i started to believe in myself
and at 29 graduated from nottingham
university
with a good first degree that process
was long and difficult and
entrenched my belief that nobody
nobody should be judged by where they
come from
nobody should have to work two three
four times as hard
to develop his or her talents and
abilities
we all have something to offer whoever
we are
most people are like my family they do
not want to be patronised
by left-wing intellectuals who think
that being
poor and working class constitutes a
state of grace
what they do want is a fair crack at the
whip and
opportunities to succeed they also
believe that
everyone in our country bears a
responsibility
to make a contribution towards keeping
our society
safe and prosperous but these values are
no longer valid in today's labour party
and that's why i have made the very
painful decision
to resign my membership and become an
independent mp
with my colleagues and friends here
today gavin will now talk about our
shared values
thank you angela my name is gavin shuker
i'm since 2010 been the member of
parliament for luton south
this is my first and only job in
politics
representing my hometown is a great
honor and i stepped up to do it because
for me
serving your community in that way is
public service
we're leaving the labour party not only
because of what it's become
but because like millions of others we
find that our values no longer find
expression
in today's broken politics we believe
ours is a great country perhaps more
importantly
so do the vast majority of the british
people
we believe that our first duty is to do
what it takes
to keep people safe we don't think every
problem in the world
is created by the west in fact we're
proud of our values
home and abroad we want to work with
other countries around the world to
tackle our shared challenges
not turn our face against them we
believe that a strong
economy delivers the best public
services and that government is the
custodian of money
that others have worked hard to earn
we back well-regulated business but in
return we expect them to provide decent
secure
and well-paying jobs we believe in the
innate creativity
of individuals people are powerful and
they're capable of taking responsibility
in their own lives they should and
government should work to remove the
barriers of poverty
prejudice and discrimination that hold
all too many back
we believe in strong democratic
institutions
a free press the rule of law and a
politics
that doesn't only bow to the loudest
voices
we're sent to parliament to exercise our
best judgment
and provide leadership we have
representatives accountable to those
that elect us
and we believe that these are values
that are shared by the majority
of the british people our friends and
our neighbors
these are values that once would have
been considered mainstream
in our parties of government but not
anymore
today they seek to set our communities
against one another
poisoning our debate and dividing our
country
at the root of today's broken politics
lie our broken political parties
guilty of a willful failure of action
and an abdication of responsibility
the complete absence of leadership at
the moment our country needs it most
competing visions of the past providing
no hope for britain's future
to express these values in today's
labour party is no longer possible
it's turned its back on the british
public
their hopes and ambitions that is why
we've taken this step today
thank you gavin good morning everybody
i'm anne coffey the member of parliament
for stockport
a town i've represented for nearly 27
years
it is a great privilege to be an mp
my father died a year before i was
elected
he would have been proud to see the
chance for a better life
he had fought to give me realized in an
achievement
beyond his dreams he believed
passionately
in education but without the wilson's
government's commitment to providing
alternative routes to higher education
through expanding places in polytechnics
i would not have got a degree
hope and determination of an individual
by itself
is not enough i spent 20 years working
as a social worker with families
but social work cannot be a response to
inequality
and lack of opportunity i joined the
labour party
41 years ago to elect governments that
understood
that real opportunity for families only
comes when the right policies
are in place i am proud of the
achievements
of the last labour government i thought
i would be in the labour
party for the rest of my life but
political parties are not an
end in themselves in a parliamentary
democracy
the labour party has lost sight of this
it is no longer a broad church any
criticism of the leadership is responded
to with abuse
and and and accusations of treachery
anti-semitism is rife and tolerated
the current leadership have been very
successful at
changing this party beyond recognition
and in doing so is failing the people
who have supported the labour party
all their lives and who i joined to help
loyalty cannot be an end in itself
so i leave the party with great sadness
but in hope
that we as an independent group can
start to change a political system
in which people feel they have no voice
i remain totally committed to continuing
to serve my constituents
our values haven't changed my values
haven't changed
i'm mike gapes the member of parliament
for ilford south
i've always considered myself
labour to my core i grew up
in a working-class family in a council
house in chigwell
essex my dad was a postman
and trade union branch secretary
my mum was worked in a news agent shop
my parents my education
at bucketstill county high school a year
i spent as a voluntary service overseas
teacher in swaziland
before i went to cambridge university
all taught me the importance
of fighting racism poverty
and injustice
i joined the labour party more than 50
years ago
in 1968 i've been active
at all levels since then
from young socialist branch treasurer
to chair of the national organization of
labour students
and i worked for 15 years in the labour
party headquarters
including as head of the international
section of the party
and since 1992 i have been the labour
and cooperative
member of parliament for ilford south
i am sickened that the labour party is
now
a racist anti-semitic party
i'm furious that the labour leadership
is complicit in facilitating brexit
which will cause great economic social
and political damage to our country
jeremy corbyn and those around him
are on the wrong side on so many
international issues
from russia to syria to venezuela
the corbyn labour government would
threaten our national security
and international alliances
now this is personally very difficult
for me
i've got lots of very good friends
locally
nationally and internationally through
the labour party
but i must be true to myself
and my values
it's been a great privilege and honor to
serve
my fantastic constituents in ilford
south for 27 years
and i intend to continue to represent
them
as a member of the new independent group
thanks mike uh i'm chikuramana i'm the
member of parliament for streatham the
area i'm from
and grew up in as you've heard from
all of the contributions the values
which have driven our decision today
are shaped by who we are where we are
from
our experiences i'm of mixed heritage
uh you might not be able to tell i'm a
quarter english a quarter
irish and half nigerian my forebears
came to this country
driven by the hope and optimism that if
you put the effort in
you can get on and lead a good life in
britain
my father arrived from nigeria with no
money
and he worked his way up to become a
successful entrepreneur
in spite of the prejudice he experienced
the platform this country gave him to
succeed
was britain at its very best
but we've had our ups and our downs he
the only breadwinner in the family was
killed in a car crash when i was just
13. his death taught me
that regardless of your circumstances
people need one another
we want our families to get on in the
good times but my gosh
we need to support each other through
the bad times
too many in britain face barriers in
fulfilling their dreams
their potential and people don't get the
support that they need
we believe it doesn't have to be that
way fundamental change is needed
now the last few years have shown the
established parties are simply
not up to this challenge they can't be
the change because they have become
the problem they have failed to provide
the leadership and clear direction which
the uk
desperately needs they are deeply
divided
they have failed to fulfill their duties
with the competence the public rightly
deserves
they've put their party political
interest before the national interest
and they don't represent the complex
tapestry
which is modern britain now there are
those who will say there is
no alternative we are doomed to be
saddled with the same old politics
that we have to settle for voting for
the least worst option or you know
simply to keep the other lot
out stop them from getting in that no
matter how incompetent
they are we have no option but to vote
for these people
we reject this completely when our
democracy is failing
the british people have overcome the
hurdles over history to build a better
future
we demanded elected mps take precedence
over
unelected lords we insisted working men
and women have the vote we said our
parliament should better reflect and
look like the country in terms of gender
and ethnicity and now we have got to
change our politics
again it is time we dumped this
country's old-fashioned politics and
created an alternative
that does justice to who we are today
and gives this country a politics fit
for the here and now the 21st century
not the last one so we've taken the
first step in leaving the old tribal
politics behind
and we i and we invite others who share
our political values to do so too you
might come
from a labour background but you might
come from
other political traditions and yes it's
a difficult decision make no mistake
about that but think about it
you don't join a political party to
spend years
and years fighting the people within it
you get involved in politics you join
the party
to change the world so we invite you
to leave your parties and help us forge
a new consensus
on a way forward for britain we will sit
together
as an independent group of mps in the
house of commons from here on
we haven't yet assigned roles or
responsibilities between us but we will
have our first formal meeting as a new
group of mps in the coming days
we want to finish today by speaking
directly
to the people who send us here the
british people
for far too long political parties in
westminster parties of which we've been
apart
have been failing you if you're sick and
tired of politics as usual well guess
what
so are we that's why we've done what
we've done today
and why we commit to do things
differently we don't
have all the answers so we'll treat
people like adults
and be honest about the tough choices
facing britain
we don't have the big money or
infrastructure of the political parties
all we can do is direct you to our
website please sign up
and we're asking you to help us shape
what the next steps should be building
a new politics cannot be done in
committee rooms in westminster so we
want to invite you
the british people to join us in this en
endeavor
if you want an alternative please help
us build it
the bottom line is this politics is
broken
it doesn't have to be this way let's
change it